PHIL MORIARTY: We're talking
about something called tau,
which is equal to 2 pi.
So there's been a huge amount of
debate and discussion about
this right across
the internet.
There's even a Tau Manifesto.
So one of the real advocates
of tau versus pi is ViHart,
and I really recommend you
go and visit her videos.
Brady might put the link in
somewhere-- maybe down here or
up there or over there--
somewhere.
For some people, it's
not an issue.
And initially, my response
was what are people
arguing about this?
This is total nonsense, because
if you want to use
tau, then you just go tau--
I'll repeat it-- tau is equal
to 2 pi, and then proceed.
It's more than that though,
because, with maths and with
physics, what you want to strive
for all the time is
clarity, particularly when
you're teaching this stuff.
It's far too easy, if you've
been teaching this for 15
years like I have, not to be
able to put yourself in the
mindset who's doing this
right from the start.
And so if you're got
schoolchildren who are coming
to trigonometry, who are coming
to angles, who are
coming to pi and circles and
circumferences and radius for
the first time, you do not
want to confuse them.
You want to minimize
the confusion.
And moreover, in maths and in
physics, a really important
property is symmetry.
And you want to try and have
the most elegant, concise
description of something.
Here's my very wonky circle.
And let's put our
center there.
And that's our radius r.
And from there to there,
you all know, I hope--
let's do it in a different
color--
is d.
And we define pi, very simply,
as the ratio of the
circumference to the diameter.
And this holds true
for any circle,
regardless of its size.
Pi crops up in very many
different ways.
And the first thing we've got
to think about is how we
define angle.
So let's draw another
circle on this very
crumply brown paper.
If we start here at this point
and we move around and come
back to the same point, that's
how many degrees, Brady?
BRADY HARAN: 360.
PHIL MORIARTY: 360 degrees.
So there's a much more natural
way of defining an angle.
Let's take a circle again.
Here's our radius.
We're going to call
that r again.
And let's say that, instead of
walking all the way around, we
instead walk a distance
r along here.
So that's r as well.
And we call angles,
conventionally, in physics--
you can call it whatever you
like, but conventionally, we
denote it by theta.
That angle, when this arc length
is equal to the radius,
is equal to 1 radian.
OK.
So that's a much more natural
definition, because here,
we're basing it on
just fundamental
properties of the circle.
Instead of going, well, that's
360 degrees, we're saying that
when we go around a certain arc
length which is equal to
the radius, that's a radian.
Now, the question is, how many
radians do we get if we go all
the way around the circle?
How many radians does
that turn out to be?
Well, it turns out to
be 2 pi radians.
And the reason is--
because you remember that
the circumference
length is 2 pi r.
All right?
So 2 pi radians.
Here's where the debate
kicks in.
Some, particularly
Bob Palais--
I hope I've pronounced
that right.
It all stems from
this wonderful
paper, "Pi is Wrong"--
Bob Palais.
What he argued--
well, isn't this rather
confusing?
So you go around one turn, and
instead of being pi radians,
it's 2 pi radians.
I have a daughter who's
nine and another
daughter who's six.
And my daughter who's nine is
starting to look at shapes and
starting to look at angles,
doing basic geometry.
And I can see how this is going
to be a big problem.
I'm looking around
for the paper.
And what we're going to do now
is we're going to look at a
number of different angles.
So we define angles
counterclockwise.
So we go that way rather
than that way.
Quite why we do that,
I have no idea.
It's convention.
Here's where it gets
interesting.
0 radians--
exactly the same.
We go around a quarter
of the circle.
That angle is not pi over 4.
It's pi over 2.
That's already confusing.
We go around the circle
a bit more.
Instead at of being pi over 2,
because we've gone half way
around, it's pi.
And here, it's 1 and 1/2 pi--
3 pi over 2--
and here, it's 2 pi.
A natural unit is one turn.
A natural unit is you
go around once.
And yet, when you go around
once, that's 2 pi.
Now, I think that's confusing,
not just at a basic elementary
level, but that use of 2 pi
instead of pi or instead of
something which represents one
turn, which represents one
revolution--
well, let's just
redefine that.
Let's say that tau
is equal to 2 pi.
One turn is equal to 2 pi.
And let's just put the
pi thing to one side.
So that's one turn.
So we start off with 0.
How far have we gone?
Well, we've gone a quarter
way around.
We've done a quarter
of a revolution.
That's tau over 4--
much more natural.
This is tau over 2.
Because we've gone halfway
around, it's natural.
What's this one, Brady?
BRADY HARAN: That's going
to be 3/4 of tau.
PHIL MORIARTY: Exactly.
And this one's going to be tau,
and then 2 tau and 3 tau
and 4 tau and 5 tau.
And that's much more natural.
And of course, any professional
physicist or
mathematician or scientist is
going to go, well, it's
straightforward.
If I want to use that, I just
write that and I continue my
equation, my analysis.
I continue my derivation
using tau.
But that's not the point.
It's not about the professional
physicists.
It's about teaching
this stuff.
2 pi appears throughout physics,
all the way from the
very large scale, all
the way right
down to quantum mechanics.
And I'll get on to quantum
mechanics in a sec.
Let me show you a simple
demo, first of all.
Mass on a spring--
we let that bob up and down, it
performs something which is
the bane of so many first year
undergraduates' lives in
physics, which is called
simple harmonic motion.
It goes up and down.
What describes that?
Oh, we call it circular
motion.
And what describes that
is a sine wave.
And the period of that motion,
again, is 2 pi.
In terms of how atoms vibrate,
atoms vibrate
all the time in molecules.
We describe that in terms
of an angular frequency.
We describe in terms of a
frequency, but often, we use
something called omega, which is
an angular frequency, which
is 2 pi times f.
And this is where it gets
really, really interesting,
because even as physicists, we
even extract out that factor
of 2 pi, because we
have something
called Planck's constant.
It's a fundamental constant
that crops up throughout
quantum mechanics.
And we actually redefine it.
And we have got something
called h-bar.
And h-bar is equal
to h over 2 pi.
And one of the reasons this 2
pi factor crops up time and
time again throughout physics
is that when we get down to
the quantum level, matter
behaves like a wave.
It's got oscillatory motion
associated with it.
It moves back and forth
with a period.
We can describe that in terms
of waves, which have
a period of 2 pi.
It crops up absolutely
everywhere.
Here's my favorite equation.
That is called Fourier
transform.
And as you'll see, you've
got 2 pi here.
But, not only do you
have 2 pi there--
that's an omega, which is 2 pi
f-- you've got a 2 pi factor
and there's another
omega up here.
What that does--
BRADY HARAN: That's got
2 pis everywhere.
PHIL MORIARTY: That's got 2
pis absolutely everywhere.
Now, what we could do--
and you can just replace this
instead of having 1 over root
2 pi, have 1 over tau here,
have 1 over root tau.
That's not the point.
I really don't think
that's the point.
If you go to the various
websites--
where are they?
The tau manifesto and
the pi manifesto--
and they have this game
where they bat each
other back and forth.
Look, this equation's more
simple if you put tau and this
equation's more simple
if you put pi in.
That's not the point.
It's about the fundamental
teaching of this.
For professionals physicists,
we're not
going to change this.
I really do not think we are
If you open up any textbook,
there's a 2 pi.
2 pi there, actually.
There's one already
earlier on.
So open a book up at random.
You're very, very likely in a
first-year physics textbook or
in any physics textbook
to come across a 2 pi.
We are not going to change
these textbooks.
That's not the point.
The point is when you're
teaching this stuff, tau is a
better representation,
is a better concept.
The idea that you do one turn
and that's tau, as opposed to
2 pi radians.
That's just a much better
way of explaining it.
BRADY HARAN: If no one's going
to change, why are we even
talking about it?
Are just we just saying this is
what we should have done?
PHIL MORIARTY: Yes, it is what
we should have done.
Euler, I think, possibly had an
opportunity to change this
hundreds of years ago.
We should have done it.
We haven't done it.
Perhaps we could, from this
point onwards, think about
writing textbooks and at
least mention tau.
I think what we need
to do is you can--
perhaps in a textbook like this,
throughout it's going to
talk about 2 pi.
But we could say right at the
start that there is this
concept of tau--
many students find
it very helpful--
and introduce it.
And perhaps, then, there
will be a gradual
evolution towards tau.
I doubt it.
I really doubt it, but it might
be nice to think so.
-You've got to keep in your
mind when you're doing
calculations--
and actually, if you're a
seasoned mathematician--
PHIL MORIARTY: --the sampling
and the effects and frequency
shifting to get it into
the right pitch.
But I'll play you Vi's vocals
again, because they are really
quite neat, if I can
find the channel.
-And also, that 1/2's here,
because the half tells you
something.
-This works out just as nicely.